[Music]
so uh
my name is davis vaughn i'm a software
engineer at rstudio as max said this was
supposed to be my
beautiful e-poster that was going to be
shown at the
introduction and it was not so i'm
going to talk about this but this looks
horrible so i'm just going to scrap it
entirely and start over
so this is a talk about two packages the
first one is called slider and the
second one is called almanac yes i'm
going to do two packages in five minutes
so slider is a package for rolling and
expanding windows
if you've ever used zoos roll apply or
sybil's slide before
this is kind of the more supercharged
version of those so
with the function slide you take a
vector
as input you take a function that you
want to apply to different sliding
windows of that vector
and then you can control the window size
with these extra arguments
the only one i'm going to talk about
today is the before argument
so here what this is saying is for each
element
i'm going to take that current element
of the vector
and look one element before as well
and that's going to make up my sliding
window so at the bottom here there's
another example of a
a different type of rolling window with
before equals two
and if yet the animation is going so
you're saying
six back to four seven back to five
and then with the expanding window you
can actually do things such as
cumulative sums uh or other different
types of expanding ones
so for that you set before equals to
infinity
which says give me the current element
plus everything before
this is supposed to have very very very
similar syntax to per
slide is very much like map in fact the
defaults are the same
and then it always returns a list it's
completely type and size stable
there are variants such as slide double
slide dfr slide two and p slide
everything that you might expect with
per there is in slide as well
i'm more excited though about the fact
that there's this idea of
time aware sliding built into this
package
so slide index is this other function
and it allows you to pass this secondary
date like normally secondary index and
what this means
is that if you have this example here
and whether you can or cannot see it
we've got a vector and then this
secondary index where it's
one two four and then five
you can think of those like days of the
month the first second fourth and fifth
day of the month
if i want to take the current element
and one day
backwards that might be kind of
problematic here because we have an
irregular gap in this series but slide
index is smart enough to know that when
you're on the second day
you want a range of days one to two and
when you're on the fourth day
you want a range of days three to four
so it knows that in that third function
call
you don't want day two so slide doesn't
know how to do this on its own because
it doesn't have that extra index
but slide index does kind of solving
this completely new problem
that that's really useful in time series
analysis
so almanac is a completely different
package it kind of came out of a use
case for slide
where i really needed to control
weekends and holidays
so you can create kind of a holiday
object with almanac
by starting with this base frequency
like yearly or weekly
and then you add on these recurrence
conditions for labor day
it happens in september and it's on the
first monday in september
then you can do fun things with that
object like say what days
are labor day returns yes or no
i'm more excited for almanac about these
lubridate extensions
though we have this bdays object that
you can use
so in the bottom right corner there say
that we're on friday and we want to go
one day ahead you might use luber date
days and just say
plus one day that takes you to saturday
but in the business world if i was on
friday
one business day ahead is actually
monday
and if monday is a holiday it might
actually be tuesday
with almanac you can kind of bake in
this scheduling logic of what are
holidays what are weekends
what are the events that you're
interested in and then create this
b days object in the bottom left with
that schedule
which says skip over these events so in
the bottom right there we have friday
plus one business day
takes me to monday lastly slider and
almanac are made to play very well
together
when you use slide index in conjunction
with these
b days objects you can say for example
if i'm on monday look back one business
day
that creates a range of friday to monday
and that kind of gives that nuanced
difference in that third function call
there on the right
and that is slider and almanac thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's uh